do you remember when President Obama was
President of the United States most of
you do up the entire Obama's coming for
your guns thing lasted basically the
full eight years right accusations that
the Sandy Hook attacks were a false flag
to create a pretext for Obama to take
guns the reality was no significant gun
reform was passed under President Obama
not even basic mandatory background
checks which the overwhelming majority
of Americans on the left and right
approve of and agree with the reality is
that we ended up seeing effectively no
seizures of guns under President Obama
and record gun sales under President
Obama conversely a growing reality is
that gun sales are suffering Bigley
under Donald Trump Remington has laid
off more than a hundred employees in the
last month one executive said that the
company was expecting quote a different
political climate on a recent conference
call with investors representatives from
Remington said that the results of the
November election sapped consumer demand
for firearms Jurgen Brower
the founder of small-arms analytics said
gun sales are below expectations in
January his company had predicted that
about four point three million guns
would be sold during the first three
months of the year about four hundred
thousand fewer guns than the estimate
were actually sold during the first
quarter of 2017 it turns out that that
what is perceived as a friendlier White
House to guns is really bad for gun
business and the irony here is that the
NRA which represents the gun
manufacturer should actually be
supporting Democrats right because when
Democrats get into power they either try
to effect gun legislation or they just
don't touch it at all because it's a way
to touch you of a subject if you don't
think someone's coming for your guns you
don't buy as many guns I've said it
before and I'll say it again what's good
for gun sales is number one violence
which makes people feel afraid so they
go out and buy guns and number two the
threat even if it's an imaginary threat
of gun restrictions which makes you go
out and buy guns before the restrictions
are put in place we have
neither right now and there is a pitch
that companies like companies III call
it a company but organizations like the
NRA make during so-called good times for
gun rights which is they go out and they
say hey we're really safe right now
because of guns and the more guns you
buy the safer we'll be
it's a more difficult pitch because
people react way more to fear and I've
said it before even Noam Chomsky said it
a few days after I did the Trump White
House would benefit from a terror attack
we're already seeing a little bit of
benefit from what's going on in Syria
the escalation in the Korean Peninsula
we've seen terror in Egypt etc gun sales
also benefit from that type of thing
that's just the reality and I'm not a
false-flag
conspiracy guy I'm just laying it out as
I see it both the Trump White House and
gun manufacturers would benefit from a
major terrorist attack or the fear of
one yeah and the paranoia coming from
the gun owning community when Democrats
are in charge is just completely
illogical because even when they had the
presidency after the Sandy Hook massacre
they couldn't pass something as benign
as background checks for everyone that's
right and when that should really be the
proof that it's very difficult to do
anything significant with gun safety you
had attacks which had the reality of
shootings mass shootings which had the
idea of guns being used to commit
horrible crimes on people's minds you
had 85 percent agreement that there
should be universal background checks
eliminating the so-called gun show
loophole and you still could not get it
passed and part of this also has to do
Pat with the reality that our elected
officials don't actually do the will of
their constituents because when you have
eighty-five percent of the population of
the country saying yeah pass 100%
coverage background checks background
checks for any gun transaction period
and you still don't have our elected
officials getting it passed clearly it's
not because there isn't constituent will
to do it it's because the elected
officials are not representing the will
of the people in their legislation
luckily there was some backlash though
because Kelly Ayotte the senator from
New Hampshire right lost her seat and I
think a big part of that had to do with
her vote against universal background
check now Trump said she lost it because
she didn't support him or something
right well why would you take his
argument ya know I'm not I'm just saying
it's funny how Trump had a whole
different perspective as to why Kelly
Ayotte lost her seat was she big picture
like a more reasonable Republican in
your mind I saw her that way but I might
have been influenced by the fact that
she's from New Hampshire and and
northeastern Republicans are just
generally conceived of as less crazy
like Susan Collins from Maine not that I
agree with everything Susan Collins says
but do you like are you familiar with
actual policy I think just living in a
swing state you're incentivized to go
more towards the center I mean you'll
get even the Democratic Senator Joe
Manchin he's practically a Republican
because he's from West Virginia yeah
that is interesting that's for sure
so anyway gun sales not doing too well